Hallo und herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ja, ich begrüße alle hier zu einer neuen Ausgabe, die ja das erste Mal nicht direkt in Deutschland aufgenommen wird an einem der Standorte von DLR und ESA in Deutschland, sondern ich befinde mich jetzt in den Niederlanden, genauer beim ASTEC in der Nähe von Leiden bzw. Den Haag, dem großen Testing Facility Zentrum der ESA. Und das Thema soll heute sein, das ATV, das Automated Transfer Vehicle, ein Raumfahrzeug der ESA, was eine besondere Rolle spielt, insbesondere für die ESS, aber auch eine besondere Rolle spielt für die ESA. Und ich freue mich dafür, als Gesprächspartner Nico, Nico Dettmann, zu begrüßen. Du bist ATV Program Department Head, wie das so schön heißt. Also leitest die Abteilung, die sich hier vor Ort konkret um das Projekt ATV kümmert.
Das stimmt so.
Und was schließt das alles mit ein? Schließt das alles mit ein?
Das umschließt mehrere Bereiche. Erstmal, um ATV-Missionen durchzuführen, braucht man ja ein Launch-Vehikel. Also die Beschaffung der Ariane 5, auf der der ATV fliegt, ist mit in der Verantwortung dieses Departments. Dann haben wir natürlich ein Vertrag mit der Industrie, die diese ATVs entwickelt und baut, integriert, inklusive der Integration am Launch-Site. Und darüber hinaus sind verschiedene operationelle Aspekte in diesem Departement abgedeckt. Seit Kurzem ist in diesem Departement auch die Verantwortung für das Kontrollzentrum in Toulouse mit innenbegriffen. Und wir haben aber auch noch Verträge mit unseren russischen Partnern, eben mit der russischen Raumfahrtagentur, was die Instandhaltung und Bereitstellung aller Equipments betrifft, die onboard der Internationalen Raumstation notwendig sind, um ATV zu empfangen.
Wer noch nicht verstanden hat, wovon wir eigentlich reden, müssen wir natürlich noch mal ein bisschen ausholen. Das ATV ist hier schon in zahlreichen Ausgaben von Raumzeit in irgendeiner Form zur Sprache gekommen, zuletzt vor allem in der Sendung über Raumstationen mit Reinhold Ewald. Hierbei handelt es sich um eines der Versorgungsfahrzeuge der ISS, das also hochgeschossen wird, um dort anzudocken und ja, Versorgungsgüter mitzubringen. Das ist eine Astronauten, aber sozusagen alles andere. Und ja, kehrt dann später wieder zurück zur Erde, landet allerdings nicht. Wie ist denn das bei der ISS? Also das ATV ist ja nicht das einzige Versorgungsfahrzeug. Welchen Bedarf hat denn die Raumstation, während sie so im All schwebt? Was muss außer Astronauten denn dort noch hingebracht werden?
Also erst mal, welchen Bedarf die ISS hat, hängt natürlich auch davon ab, wie viele Astronauten sind da oben und was ist das wissenschaftliche Programm, das dort abgehandelt werden soll. Im Moment haben wir sechs Astronauten an Bord der Station und es ist auch das Ziel, diese sechs Astronauten Langzeit an Bord der Station haben. Die wechseln natürlich andauernd, aber es ist das Ziel, kontinuierlich sechs Astronauten an Bord zu haben.
Im Moment heißt Mai 2011, das ist der Zeitpunkt dieser Aufnahme, dass die zweite ATV-Mission gerade vor kurzem gestartet, erfolgreich und befindet sich jetzt auch gerade an der ISS und kehrt demnächst zurück.
Ja, das ist richtig. ATV 2 soll am 20. Juni nach derzeitiger Planung von der Station abdocken und einen Tag später soll er dann seinen kontrollierten Re-Entry im Südpacific haben. Nochmal zur Frage zurück, wofür ATV und was macht ATV genau? ATV ist das vielseitigste Logistikvehikel, in dem Sinne, dass es sehr verschiedene Bedarfe der ISS deckt. Ich fange mal an. Es hat also auf der einen Seite Gastanks, die die ISS mit Gas versorgen können, wobei ATV drei verschiedene Gase transportieren kann. Es kann Wasser transportieren.
Was für Gase benötigt denn?
Wir reden von entweder Sauerstoff, reines Reinsauerstoff, Atemluft oder auch Stickstoff. Zum Beispiel brauchen bestimmte Experimente Stickstoff. Kann auch unterschiedliche Gase transportieren. Das zweite, was es eben tun kann, ist Wasser transportieren. ATV hat eine Wassertankkapazität von 840 Kilogramm. Das sind drei Tanks. Jeder dieser Tank kann einzeln betankt werden. Es hat weiterhin das sogenannte Refueling System an Bord. Das sind 860 Kilogramm von den Treibstoffen, die von dem russischen FGB, das ist ein Modul der ISS, gebraucht werden. Das sind andere Treibstoffe, als die die ATV selber benutzt. Das heißt, das ist ein unabhängiges Betankungssystem an Bord des ATVs, der die Tanks der ISS auffüllen kann, weil auch die ISS selbstständig ohne andere Vehikel sogenannte Lage-Regelungsmanöver durchführen kann. Dann wird ATV, während es an der ISS angedockt ist, fast für alle Lage-Regelungsoperationen der gesamten ISS benutzt. Das beinhaltet nicht nur die nominelle Lage-Regelung, um die ISS einfach in ihrer Position zu halten, sondern insbesondere auch spezielle Manöver, zum Beispiel beim Undocking oder Docking von Progress-Vehikeln. ATV führt aber auch mit der gesamten Station sogenannte Collision Avoidance Manöver durch, oder es heißt eigentlich Debris Avoidance Manöver. Es ist ja so, dass an die Nase alle Partikel track, die größer als 10 Quadratzentimeter sind und deshalb also weiß, wann die ISS gegebenenfalls Ausweichmanöver fliegen muss. Und diese werden solange ATV angedockt ist, mit dem Antriebssystem des ATVs bewältigt.
Das heißt aber sonst hätte die ISS auch die Möglichkeit auszuweichen. Aber in dem Moment, wo die ATV da ist, nimmt man die ATV, damit jetzt nicht noch Treibstoff verbraucht wird.
Das ist richtig. Aufgrund der Position von ATV, nämlich er ist an der Längsachse angedockt, hat das ATVs Antriebssystem den größten Wirkungsgrad, um überhaupt Manöver mit der ISS zu fliegen.
Das heißt, man verbraucht am wenigsten Treibstoff, um ein bestimmtes Manöver zu machen, auch wenn die ISS es alleine könnte. Verstehe.
Und die zwei Dinge, die noch fehlen, das eine ist, ATV wird auch benutzt, um den sogenannten ISS-Reboost zu machen. Das heißt, die ISS verliert an Höhe, aufgrund des noch vorhandenen atmosphärischen Widerstands, auch wenn er sehr gering ist, sie würde automatisch an Höhe verlieren. Und ATV aufgrund seiner besonderen Position, angedockt am Service-Modul, hat den besten Wirkungsgrad, um dann die ISS insgesamt anzuheben. Wenn wir uns jetzt die ATV-2-Mission angucken, dort gibt es ein besonders großes Reboost. Weil nachdem das Shuttle ja in sehr kurzer Zeit in den Ruhestand gehen wird, kann die ISS einen sehr viel höheren Orbit fliegen. Und ATV-2 wird insgesamt die Station um 40 km anheben. Bisher war es eben so, dass der Orbit der ISS niedrig gehalten wurde, um eine möglichst hohe Upload-Performance der Shuttles zu erlauben.
Also möglichst viel beladen zu können, ohne dass er so viel Treibstoff mitnehmen muss, um noch höher fliegen zu können.
Und jetzt, wo das Shuttle eben in kürzeren Ruhestand gehen wird, kann man die ISS etwas höher fliegen lassen. Das heißt, es gibt dann weniger von diesem sogenannten Residual Drag, von diesem verbleibenden atmosphärischen Widerstand. Und die ISS wird dann also weniger absinken über die Dauer. Last but not least, ATV bringt natürlich auch die sogenannte Dry Cargo. Das sind also all das, was sich im Inneren des sogenannten Integrated Cargo Carrier des ATVs befindet. Das sind Dry Cargo, darunter fällt zum Beispiel Kleidung für die Astronauten, Experimente, Ersatzteile, all das, was an Bord gebraucht wird, entweder für die Astronauten selber oder um die Station oder Experimente durchzuführen.
So, das war jetzt schon mal eine ganze Menge. Ich fasse mal so ein bisschen zusammen. Also grundsätzlich ist es so, die ISS benötigt permanente Zuführung von Gasen, von Treibstoff und auch von Zeug, sage ich mal. Kleidung, Experimente, die sich ja auch wandeln. Wobei jetzt nur hingebracht wird, das ATV ist nicht in der Lage, irgendetwas auch wieder zurückzubringen.
Stimmt nicht ganz.
Stimmt nicht ganz?
Also ATV nimmt eine Menge mit wieder zurück. Es ist halt dann nur nicht wiederverwendbar. Also ATV wird, wenn man so will, auch bevor es andockt, als Mülleimer benutzt. Also sprich, es werden sogenannte Waste Liquids, auf Deutsch würde man so sagen, nicht mehr verwendete oder verschmutzte Flüssigkeiten, so wie Urin zum Beispiel, wird dann wieder in die Wassertanks eingeladen. Und auch das Innere des sogenannten Cargo Carriers wird natürlich benutzt, um all die Trockenmaterialien, die an Bord der ISS nicht mehr benutzt werden, wegzuwerfen und die dann mit beim Re-Entry eben verbrennen. Ist aber richtig, ATV ist kein wiederverwendbares Vehikel. Insofern können zum Beispiel Proben von Experimenten, die weiter auf der Erde untersucht werden müssen, die kommen für ATV nicht in Frage.
Wie häufig ist denn jetzt so eine Versorgung der ISS überhaupt erforderlich? Das ATV ist ja nicht das einzige Versorgungsfahrzeug, was die ISS regelmäßig besucht. Dazu gehört ja auch das Space Shuttle, was wir schon erwähnt haben. Jetzt geht das Space Shuttle demnächst außer Dienst. Das heißt ja, dass eigentlich der Bedarf für alle anderen Versorgungsfahrzeuge noch steigt, oder?
Also erstmal ist es so, welche Vehikel gibt es? Von dem Shuttle werden also noch zwei fliegen, das letzte dann im Juli diesen Jahres. Zum Austausch der Kuh gibt es dann nur noch das Soyuz der Russen. Soyuz ist auch zurzeit das einzige Vehikel, das nach dem Shuttle dann noch erlaubt, bis zu 60 Kilogramm an Material wieder zur Erde zurückzubringen. Darüber hinaus gibt es natürlich auch das russische Progress als Versorgungsvehikel, das fliegt bis zu fünfmal im Jahr. Dann gibt es noch das japanische HTV, das fliegt so ähnlich wie der ATV einmal pro Jahr. Das ist zurzeit die Planung. Und dann gibt es, das ist aber bisher noch nicht angedockt, gibt es noch das amerikanische Programm CRS, steht für Commercial Resupply Services, das die Nase aufgesetzt hat, um einen Ersatz für das Shuttle zu schaffen. Das sind also zwei Firmen, SpaceX und Orbital, die dabei sind, kommerzielle Logistik-Vehikel für die ISS zu qualifizieren. Und sie sollen im Laufe des Jahres 2012, 2013 operationell in Betrieb genommen werden. Und würden dann, so ist die Theorie, die Serviceleistung des Shuttles ersetzen.
Also es gibt fünf Versorgungsfahrzeuge im Prinzip. Soyuz, das ist auch das, womit die Astronauten hochkommen, aber da ist noch ein bisschen Platz. Das heißt, man kann sowohl was hinbringen und es kehrt natürlich auch vollständig wieder zurück, weil man will ja auch die Astronauten wieder zurückhalten.
Und das, was man da noch an Nutz-Lassmuss reinpacken kann, ist sehr limitiert.
Ist wenig, genau. Progress fliegt fünfmal, kehrt auch nicht zurück. Das heißt, die werden immer gebaut und verglühen wieder. Und ist das Progress jetzt im Vergleich zu, also wie muss man sich jetzt die Größen der einzelnen Dinger relativ zueinander vorstellen? Ist das alles so im Wesentlichen gleich?
Ich denke, die richtige Dimension, die dazu wählen wäre, ist die sogenannte Upload-Kapazität. Also wie viel Kilogramm oder Tonnen kann ein Vehikel nach oben bringen? Progress bringt durchschnittlich 1,8 Tonnen nach oben. Im Vergleich zum ATV, das nach Shuttle Retirement das größte Logistik-Vehikel sein wird, ein ATV schafft bis zu 7 Tonnen. Das hängt ein bisschen von der Beladung ab, ob das eine Mission ist, die mehr treibstofforientiert ist oder mehr 3-Carbo-orientiert ist.
Was hängt davon ab? Ist das nicht eigentlich egal, was da wiegt?
Nee, es ist nicht egal, weil es gibt bestimmte Minimum-Massen an Propellern, die einfach geladen werden müssen. Also man kann nicht unbeschränkt trockene Cargo mit Propellent austauschen. Da gibt es bestimmte Design-Grenzen.
Propellent ist jetzt Treibstoff. Ja, die Fachbegriffe sind sicherlich zahlreich. 7 Tonnen, ok. Und die anderen? HTV, also das Versorgungsfahrzeug der Japaner?
HTV ist das einzige Vehikel, das auch sogenannte External Payloads bringen kann. Das heißt also, das sind Payloads, die werden von einem Robotikarm, der an der Station sitzt, vom HTV abgenommen und dann auf ein Modul oder eine Plattform gesetzt, die sich auf der ISS befindet. Und das sind dann in der Regel vollautomatische Experimente, die im Äußeren der ISS ablaufen. Und dieser HTV ist eben ein kombiniertes Vehikel, aus externen und internen Lademassen. Bringt kein Wasser, kein Gas, keine Treibstoffe, aber hat eben die Kapazität, externe Payloads zu liefern. Und die Gesamt-Upload-Kapazität eines HTVs liegt im Bereich von 3,5 Tonnen.
Also ungefähr die Hälfte.
Und was haben dann die Amerikaner mit dem CRS so in Planung, wenn es das Shuttle ablösen soll? Ich meine, was hat denn das Shuttle bisher immer hochbringen können?
Ich glaube, das Shuttle hat ja ganze Module hochgebracht. Das Shuttle hat zum Beispiel das gesamte Columbus-Modul und die Knoten hochgebracht.
Also viel mehr.
Deutlich mehr. Das Shuttle war das größte Logistik-Vehikel, oder ist es noch? Und wird dann später von ATV abgelöst, was die Größe der Upload-Kapazität betrifft.
Aber eigentlich ist das Shuttle so ein bisschen unersetzlich in seiner Versatilität.
Es ist unersetzlich, solange man die Raumstation weiter ausbauen möchte, um neue Module hochzubringen, da die ISS jetzt ihre endgültige Größe erreicht hat. Es fehlt noch ein Modul der Russen, das können die Russen aber selber hochschicken.
Der unmittelbare Bedarf ist sozusagen nicht mehr gegeben. Aber wenn man nochmal was anderes bauen will oder ausbauen will, muss man sich erst mal überlegen, wie man das hochbekommt. Und dieses CAS?
Das CAS sind kleinere Vehicle, die sollen allerdings relativ oft fliegen, also fünf bis sechsmal pro Jahr, ähnlich wie es ProRes. Und CAS ist ja nur der Oberbegriff. Also es gibt da einmal das, das ist eines, die Dragon Capsule, das ist glaube ich von, muss ich jetzt passen, SpaceX oder...
Achso, das ist eine ganze Serie von Versorgungs...
Es sind zwei verschiedene Firmen, die zwei verschiedene Versorgungs-Vehikel bauen und beide sollen mehrfach pro Jahr fliegen.
Aber das ist noch so ein bisschen in der Zukunft?
Es hat bereits Prototypflüge gegeben, insbesondere vom Launcher Falcon 9. Es hat auch bereits seinen ersten Flug gegeben von der Dragon Capsule, die einfach blind zurückgekommen ist und einen We-Entry gemacht hat, ohne zur ISS zu fliegen. Gut, die Informationen, die man da hat, sind limitiert. Aber die NASA ist also durchaus zuversichtlich, dass diese Projekte Realität werden.
Das heißt, es gibt 8 Versorgungsflüge zur ISS pro Jahr, wenn man die ganzen Einsätze der Progress, ATV, etc. zusammenrechnet?
Die 8 wären ohne CRS. Wir haben 1 ATV, 1 HTV, ungefähr 5 Progress, 3 bis 4 Soyus pro Jahr, und jetzt kommen noch die CRS dazu. Das sind also deutlich mehr Flüge.
Da ist schon ganz schön was los, ein ganz schöner Bahnhof.
Da passiert was.
Und vor allem ist ja so, dass jetzt auch Zeit, also das ja nicht nacheinander stattfindet, sondern dass sie sich eben auch teilweise überschneiden. Also jeder hat auch sein eigenes Gleis auf diesem Bahnhof. Also jedes Modul dockt auch an seinem eigenen Port an, oder?
Es gibt an der ISS zwei verschiedene sogenannte Docking-Ports, rein vom Design her. Es gibt deutlich mehr Docking-Ports als zwei, aber es gibt zwei, die sich im Design unterscheiden. Das eine ist eben das sogenannte Russian Docking System, was auch von ATV genutzt wird, bzw. Docking-Port. Und ATV hat also ein ähnliches Docking-System oder fast identisches Docking-System, wie Soyuz und Probes. Und dann gibt es eben das amerikanische Docking-System. Das unterscheidet sich insofern, dass dort ein sogenanntes Bursing gemacht wird. Das Bursing bedeutet, ich nehme mal das Beispiel HTV. HTV fliegt in die Nähe der ISS, wird von einem Robotikarm gegriffen und dieser setzt HTV dann an diesen Docking-Port und dockt ihn an. Also HTV fliegt nicht selber an einen Docking-Port.
Sondern er wird einfach eingefangen.
Beim Shuttle war das wieder ein bisschen anders. Der Shuttle hat eigene Lage-Regelung und eigene Mittel, um sich selber am Docking-Port anzudocken, muss also nicht von einem Robotikarm abgeholt werden. Wie das bei den CRS-Vehikeln ist, muss ich gestehen, weiß ich nicht. De facto werden sie aber an diese Docking-Ports der Amerikaner gehen. Man unterscheidet also das amerikanische Design des Docking-Ports und das russische.
Und ATV benutzt das russische. Das heißt, da, wo das ATV andockt, könnten theoretisch auch die Progress-Kapseln andocken?
Das ist nicht nur theoretisch so, das ist so.
Also man nimmt sozusagen immer gerade das, was frei ist.
ATV kann nur auf diesen Docking-Port docken, der in der Längsachse der ISS liegt. Progress und Soyuz können auch an den, die lateral liegen, andocken.
Okay, das heißt, das ATV ist immer an diesem optimalen Anschiebepunkt angebracht?
Es gibt also auch ein Requirement, dass dieser Docking-Port so wenig wie möglich unbesetzt sein soll. Das heißt also, wenn ein ATV undockt, dann wird wenige Tage später ein Progress- oder Soyuz dort wieder andocken. Das hat was damit zu tun, dass man einfach vermeiden möchte, dass dort…
Also das ATV ab, also wenn es weg ist, dann soll so schnell wie möglich an die selbe Stelle was kommen.
Dieser Docking-Port soll so wenig wie möglich frei unbesetzt bleiben.
Oder so viel benutzt werden wie möglich.
Ja, es geht mehr darum, dass er nie frei ist, weil man vermeiden möchte, dass dort irgendwas hineinfliegt, Debris, was auch immer, was eben dann diesen Docking-Port unbrauchbar machen könnte.
Weil er so wichtig ist? Weil er ist ja auch nochmal besonders gefährdet durch diese Position.
Jeder Docking-Port ist wichtig, weil die Anzahl der Docking-Ports ist am Ende auch ausschlaggebend, wie groß die Crewgröße sein kann. Wir benutzen ja zurzeit zwei Soyus, die permanent an der ISS sind, sollte es zu einer Notfallsituation kommen, damit man die gesamte Crew von sechs Leuten evakuieren kann. Dafür brauchen wir zwei Soyus. Und diese zwei Soyus sind immer an Bord der ISS, also angedockt. Die werden ausgetauscht, alternieren sozusagen. Aber es sind immer zwei Soyus an der ISS angedockt. Also wir hatten vor kurzem diese Wahnsinns-Konfiguration, dass wir ein HTV angedockt hatten, ein ATV angedockt hatten, einen Shuttle angedockt hatten, zwei Soyus angedockt hatten. Und ich glaube, es gab auch noch einen Progress.
Also alles voll sozusagen.
Alles voll. Und weil diese Konfiguration so einmalig war, hat man also lange überlegt, ob man es wagt, das Soyus einfach mal zum Spaß abzudocken, um dann von dem Soyus ein Foto zu machen, der ISS, mit all diesen Vehikeln angedockt. Das ist dann aber an der Vernunft der Ingenieure gescheitert, dass man gesagt hat, man macht solche Operationen nicht, ich sag mal, just for fun, sondern wir wollen da oben Musiko-Minimierung betreiben und hat also dann davon abgesehen.
Aber wäre ein tolles Foto gewesen.
Ja, gut, die gibt es auch so. Das Shuttle macht natürlich immer Fotos, wenn es kommt und geht. Und insofern gibt es die gleiche Konfiguration auf dem Bild festgehalten, nur ohne Shuttle.
Ja, jetzt stelle ich mir natürlich die Frage, also seit, ESA ist ja ein Projekt, das schon lange in Planung ist. Dann hat es auch eine Weile gedauert, bis alles aufgebaut wurde und so vollständig in Betrieb genommen werden konnte, wie das heute der Fall ist. War denn das ATV da von Anfang an Teil der Planung? War das schon immer vorgesehen oder kam das erst später dazu?
ATV kam erst später dazu. Wenn wir uns zurückerinnern, als die Entwicklung von Columbus beschlossen wurde, da war ja klar, dass Columbus wird bestimmte Ressourcen der ISS brauchen, Strom, Crew, Wärmehaushalt etc. und dass die ESA diese Dienstleistung der NASA bezahlen muss bzw. durch einen adäquaten Service kompensieren muss. Und als die Entwicklung von Columbus beschlossen wurde, gab es ATV noch nicht. Die Entwicklung von ATV wurde kurze Zeit danach beschlossen, aber wie er genau aussah, was er dann alles können musste, das hat zu dem Zeitpunkt noch keiner gewusst.
Von welchem Zeitpunkt reden wir jetzt schon etwa? Also wann wurde das Projekt begonnen?
Also ATV-Entwicklung in Ansätzen 1995.
Das ist ja noch gar nicht so lange her, wenn man jetzt mal so in den Weltraumkapazitäten denkt. Na gut, aber manche Projekte brauchen ja noch eine Menge Vorlauf. Wann ist dann das erste Mal was dabei rausgekommen? Wann war der erste Flug?
Der erste Flug war am 9. März 2008. Es war ein Jules Verne. Sehr, sehr erfolgreiche Mission. Auch insofern eine besondere Mission, weil das Vehikel zum ersten Mal zur ISS geflogen ist, man die sogenannten Demo-Objectives in die Mission eingebaut hat. Das heißt, man hat verlangt, dass das Vehikel bestimmte Manöver durchführt, die den Fehlerfall verifizieren. Das heißt also, man hat den Fehlerfall simuliert. Man hat geguckt, verhält sich das Vehikel so, wie es sich im Fehlerfall verhalten sollte.
Also, dass man es nicht nur so theoretisch testet und vorsieht für den Fall das, sondern dass man es auch komplett macht.
Man hatte also was gemacht, was viele von uns ESA-Ingenieuren für sehr, sehr gefährlich gehalten haben. Gefährlich im Sinne des Missionsverlusts, aber es war eine Forderung der Partner. Man hat ATV ein sogenanntes Cumm durchführen lassen, ein Collision Avoidance Manöver, bei dem ATV in einem Null-Fehler-Toleranten-Modus liegt. Also, ATV ist normalerweise bei allen Funktionen, die missionskritisch sind, zwei-Fehler-tolerant.
Was heißt das genau?
Das heißt, wenn ein System ausfällt, übernimmt ein anderes. Und sollte das ausfallen, würde noch mal ein anderes übernehmen. Und wenn man Null-Fehler-tolerant ist, das heißt, wenn dann in der Mission ein Fehler passiert, während dieser Phase, dann ist die Mission verloren.
Wäre dann auch richtig verloren? Warum, weil man alle anderen Systeme abschaltet in dem Moment?
Es wird dann sehr, sehr schwierig, das System sozusagen zu recovern. Das ist so, wie wenn man Restart beim PC machen muss und man weiß nicht, welcher Fehler es war, der ihn zum Abstürzen gebracht hat. Und man weiß deshalb nicht, ob man es schafft, ihn wieder hochzufahren. Jules Verne hat also zwei sogenannte Escape-Manöver gemacht. Das heißt also, auf dem Weg, wenn sich ATV... Ich will es in der richtigen Reihenfolge erzählen. Erst hat man ATV dieses berühmte Kamm machen lassen, wo ATV Null-Fehler-Toleranz fliegt. Das ist ein Manöver, wo der Hauptcomputer des ATVs abgeschaltet wird, der sogenannte Monitoring and Safety Unit. Man kann sich das wie der Backup-Computer an Bord des ATVs vorstellen, übernimmt und macht also ein retrogrades Manöver, um ATV 5 km unterhalb der ISS mindestens zu bringen, egal wo er ist. Also er macht ein Manöver, was automatisch…
Was heißt retrogrades?
Rückwärts. Nicht vorwärts. Vorwärts würde er bedeuten, er hebt den Orbit an, rückwärts, er bremst und geht runter. So, egal wo ATV ist, bedeutet dieses Manöver, ich glaube es sind nicht 5 km, sondern minus 5 Meter pro Sekunde, er bringt den ATV runter und verhindert also damit auf jeden Fall eine Kollision mit der ISS, unabhängig davon, wo er gerade ist und was passiert ist. Dieses Manöver hat Jules Verne gemacht und hat praktisch, als es dann unten wieder ankam, seine Hauptcomputer wieder hochgefahren und gestartet, ging alles wunderbar und hat sich wieder in seinen normalen Modus zurückgebracht. Dann ist ATV in den sogenannten Rendezvous-Modus gegangen und hat sich also der ISS genähert, das passiert in Stufen. Das heißt also, bei 250 Metern zum Beispiel bleibt das stehen, es wird ein bestimmter Datenabgleich mit dem Kontrollzentrum gemacht und erst dann gibt das Kontrollzentrum im Nominalfall das Go bis zum nächsten Haltepunkt.
Aber jetzt sind wir schon bei dem normalen Betrieb sozusagen.
Ich bin noch dabei zu erklären, was man bei Jules Verne gemacht hat. In diesem ersten Haltepunkt bei 250 Metern hat man dann gesagt, okay, es ist zwar alles in Ordnung, aber wir simulieren jetzt den Fall, es ist nicht alles in Ordnung und lassen ATV ein sogenanntes Escape-Manöver fliegen. Dieses Escape-Manöver bedeutet nichts anderes als, dass ATV einmal um die ISS herumfliegt und binnen 48 Stunden dann wieder an dem Punkt ist, wo es gerade war, um dann ein neues Round-A-Woo-Manöver vom Beginn an durchzuführen.
Um die ISS herum, also jetzt nicht einmal im Kreis direkt in 10 Meter Abstand, sondern…
Das ist ein größerer Kreis und jetzt kommst du darauf an, wie man das…
Aber wir reden jetzt nicht von schneller als die ISS einmal um die Erde rum überholen und dann von hinten wieder kommen.
Nein, nein, so nicht.
Sondern richtig so im Kreis herum?
ATV geht dann auf einen höheren Orbit. Die ISS fliegt praktisch unten dran vorbei, wenn man so will, und ATV kommt dann hinten wieder runter. Und das dauert eben 48 Stunden. So, und das hat Jules Verne auch gemacht. Und dann hat man…
Was sollte das jetzt simulieren?
Dass er diese Fähigkeit hat, automatisch diese ISS zu umkreisen, weil dieses Manöver, die ISS zu umkreisen, passiert vollautomatisch. Da ist also kein Kontrollzentrum mehr involviert.
War das bei dem ersten Test, war das Kontrollzentrum schon noch involviert?
Bei diesem CAM-Test? Nein, das passiert auch vollautomatisch. Auch das Recovery aus diesem Modus passiert vollautomatisch.
Also das ist ja eigentlich überhaupt das Besondere am ATV, dass da alles vollautomatisch ist, deswegen auch das A vor dem TV.
Genau. Und deshalb auch 1 Million Lines of Codes in der Software. Und ich komme dann später wieder zurück, der Backup Computer, diese sogenannte Safety and Monitoring Unit, ist die erste Software, die wir nach dieser sogenannten Kategorie A, heißt das glaube ich, qualifiziert haben. Das ist also ein Qualifikationsprozess für eine Software, die man also nur bei Hochzuverlässigkeitssoftware, wenn ich das so formulieren darf, anwendet. Und das ist das erste Mal, dass in ESA so eine Software entwickelt wurde und die befindet sich in diesem Backup Computer vom ATV. Jetzt waren wir dabei, was hat Jules Verne alles an besonderen Manövern gemacht, die nicht nominell sind. Das war also einmal der CAM und dann gab es zwei Escape-Manövers, wo man also jeweils um die ISS rumgeflogen ist, warum zwei, weil man eben in verschiedenen Haltepunkten dieses Triggern des Escapes verifizieren wollte. Einmal war es ein Triggern, was vom Kontrollzentrum ausgegeben wurde und einmal wurde es sogar von der Crew getriggert, weil auch die Crew, die observiert den ATV, wenn er sich nähert und wenn die Crew irgendwelche Zweifel hat, dass ATV also sein Ziel nicht trifft oder zu schnell ist oder im falschen Winkel kommt, dann gibt es einen Knopf innerhalb der ISS.
Also Triggern heißt halt einfach den Fall auslösen, ein Knöpfchen drücken. Gibt dann so einen schönen roten Taster wahrscheinlich irgendwo.
Genau, die ist es.
Hollywoodesk ausgeleuchtet, hoffe ich.
Auf jeden Fall ist es rot. Wird hoffentlich nie gedrückt.
Aber auch das musste alles getestet werden.
Und das ist alles getestet worden. Jules Verne hatte also eine besonders anspruchsvolle Mission.
Warum wurde denn jetzt so ein hoher Wert auf diese Fehlerfälle gelegt? Ich meine, das ist ja im Prinzip bei allen Raumfahrzeugen, bei allen Missionen so, dass eben Fälle vorgesehen sind, wo mal was schiefgehen kann, aber man testet es nicht unbedingt alles durch, sondern man simuliert es im Wesentlichen alles durch.
Die Antwort ist ganz einfach. Wir sind hier in Human Spaceflight Environment und wir tun alles, um die Crew nicht zu gefährden. Und deshalb sind die Sicherheitsanforderungen ganz andere als bei einer normalen Satellitenmission.
Aber das sind auch Anforderungen, die jetzt für die anderen Komponenten der ISS teilweise auch zum Einsatz kamen?
Natürlich.
Also ist jetzt nicht so, dass nur das ATV, weil es jetzt automatisiert ist...
Das spezielle Beispiel dieses Kamm-Manövers zu benutzen, das hat man beim Shuttle nicht gemacht, weil man beim Shuttle nicht das Risiko eingehen wollte, mit einer Crew an Bord des Shuttle das Vehikel in einen Null-Fehler-toleranten-Modus zu setzen. Insofern kann man sagen, da hat ATV was gemacht, was noch nicht mal ein Shuttle gemacht hat. Das ist so.
Ja gut, aber ja, okay, man kann ja auch durch die Tests nochmal gefährden. So hätte man im schlimmsten Fall nur das ATV verloren. Aber das hat schon funktioniert. Vielleicht gehen wir nochmal so ein bisschen zurück zum Start, um jetzt auch so das Wesen dieser Automatisierbarkeit oder dieser Automatik des ATV besser greifen zu können. Also zunächst einmal startet es ganz normal wie jeder andere Satellit auch von Kuru mit einer Ariane 5, richtig?
Ja, mit einer speziellen Ariane 5. Es gibt immer noch zwei Versionen. Es gibt die Ariane 5 EKA, die insbesondere für kommerzielle Satelliten benutzt wird, mit einer Kapazität von ungefähr 10 Tonnen in den sogenannten geostationären Transferorbit. Und dann gibt es die Ariane 5 ES, das ist die Version, die ATV fliegt. Die hat keine cryogene Oberstufe, sondern eine hypergole Oberstufe, die deutlich kleiner ist, die auch insgesamt eine kleinere Performance in den GTO hat, aber eben 20 Tonnen in den sogenannten Low Earth Orbit bringen kann. Das Besondere an dieser Stufe ist, dass sie wiederzündbar ist. Diese Wiederzündbarkeit braucht ATV, um auf einen zirkularen Orbit von 260 km gebracht zu werden.
Also man nimmt diese Variante einerseits um, man muss nicht in den geostationären Orbit. Das heißt, man braucht nicht ganz so viel Power, sondern man kann das eben mehr für Nutzlast nutzen. Man braucht nicht so viel Sprit, sehe ich das richtig? Oder ist das nur eine andere Auslegung?
Ich sage mal, diese EKA-Rakete abgesehen davon, dass sie den ATV von seinem Gewicht her nicht tragen konnte, würde ja auch nicht 20 Tonnen in den GTO bringen. Wir reden hier über einen ganz anderen Orbit, nämlich einen 260 Kilometer zirkularen Orbit im Vergleich zu einem geostationären Transfer-Orbit, der in seinem Apogeum 36.000 Kilometer hoch ist. Insofern, die Leistung dieser ES ist ausreichend für diesen Orbit. Viel wichtiger ist für uns diese Wiederzündbarkeit. Diese ES-Konfiguration, da ist die Oberstufe gar nicht voll betankt, weil wir die Leistung gar nicht brauchen, wenn man so will.
Aber wenn er dann einmal in diesem zirkulären Orbit ist, muss halt immer wieder mal gezündet werden können und eben nicht nur ein einziges Mal.
Nein, die Wiederzündung wird gebraucht, um den Orbit zirkular zu machen. Wir kennen ja alle den Roman-Transfer. Man schießt mit der ersten Injektion in einen elliptischen Orbit und benutzt dann die zweite Zündung, um das Ganze zu zirkularisieren. Und die Oberstufe muss sogar deshalb in dem Fall noch wieder zündbar sein, weil es nachdem ATV separiert ist, noch eine weitere Zündung gibt, also eine dritte, um genau diese Oberstufe kontrolliert wieder runterzubringen. Weil 260 Kilometer ist ja nicht sehr hoch. Diese Stufe würde relativ schnell wieder runterkommen aufgrund des Restwiderstands in der Atmosphäre. Und die Wiederzündung, die letzte, ist notwendig, um eben das Ganze kontrolliert zu machen, um an einen bestimmten Ort runterzukommen mit dieser Oberstufe.
Das heißt, das Ding startet und die letzte Stufe wird dann überhaupt zum ersten Mal gezündet, um diesen elliptischen Orbit zu erreichen, die zweite Zündung macht einen Kreis draus und die dritte Zündung sorgt dafür, dass die Oberstufe an einem kontrollierten Fleck auf der Erde wieder ankommt.
Wenn sie diese Zündung nicht machen würde, könnte sie überall runterkommen oder überall in diesem 51,6 Injektionsgrad Orbit und damit deckt sie 80 Prozent der bevölkerten Erdoberfläche ab.
Die Stufe selbst, die dann abgesplittet wird und ab dann ist es erst nur noch der ATV?
Bereits wenn ATV separiert, ist es nur noch ATV. Und dann separiert sich praktisch Oberstufe und ATV. Und nach einer gewissen Zeit gibt es nochmal eine dritte Zündung dieser Oberstufe, um sich selbst auf einen kontrollierten Fleck der Erde runterzubringen. Oder auf einen vorgesehenen Fleck. Und ATV fliegt dann alleine weiter.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo das ATV ausgesetzt ist, übernimmt die Steuerung das ATV selbst.
Richtig.
Komplett.
Das heißt, man hat zwar Funkkontakt und man kriegt allerlei Telemetrie und weiß, wie es dem Gerät so geht. Aber die Steuerung macht das Gerät komplett selber. Ist es denn da jetzt überhaupt das erste, was es in dieser Form so macht? Oder ist es nicht bei vielen Raumfahrzeugen so, dass sie sich erstmal im Wesentlichen selber steuern?
Kommt drauf an. Es hat mit Sicherheit kein Raumfahrzeug, eine so komplexe Bahn wie der ATV, insbesondere keine, die noch adaptiert werden muss an ein anderes Vehikel. Ich meine, andere Raumfahrzeuge docken ja nirgendwo an.
Ja, es sind Satelliten, die wollen irgendwo hin.
Da sind sie dann.
Dieses ATV ist automated, das stimmt, aber immer nur für bestimmte Abschnitte. Es gibt einen Missionsabschnitt, da macht ATV alles alleine. Und dann gibt es wieder, sage ich mal, bestimmte Kontrollpunkte, wo das Kontrollzentrum A verifiziert, oder B, auch bestimmte Daten uploaden muss, damit ATV den Weg macht, den es machen soll. Und diese Daten hängen also ab von WoS, ISS und so weiter.
Das heißt, das Ding ist schon automatisch, aber es ist nicht vollständig autonom, sondern es interagiert immer wieder mit der Kontrollstation, macht Pausen und fragt so, was soll ich jetzt als Nächstes tun? Was soll ich als Nächstes alleine tun? Aber es gibt konkrete Vorgaben.
Ja, so kann man es vereinfachen.
Wann ist dann sozusagen der nächste Punkt? Also ab dem Moment, wo es ausgesetzt ist, das ist dann wieder so eine automatische Phase?
Also in dem Moment, wo die Separation stattgefunden hat. Hier gibt es übrigens eine Besonderheit. Die Separation wird nicht wie bei anderen Satelliten vom Satelliten initiiert, sondern hier wird die Separation vom Launcher initiiert. Der Launcher gibt das Signal, so jetzt separiere den ATV. Nach dieser Separation gibt es eine ganze Reihe von automatischen Prozessen. Zum Beispiel die Sonnensegel werden alleine ausgefahren.
Derer hat es vier.
Derer hat es vier. Der Star Tracker wird aktiviert, um zu gucken, wo bin ich. Das Propulsion-System wird geprimed. Das sind Voroperationen, um das Antriebssystem scharf zu schalten. Es sind bestimmte Operationen erforderlich im ATV, um das Antriebssystem, wenn es dann gebraucht wird, voll funktionsfähig zu haben. Diese Operationen passieren alle alleine. Auch das Deployment des sogenannten Antennas. Das ist eine bestimmte Antenne, die wird ausgefahren. Die steht dann so aufrecht, sieht man auch auf allen Bildern vom ATV, die später erst für den Raumniveau gebraucht wird. Diese Manöver passieren alle vollautomatisch. Dafür gibt es sogenannte OMPs, steht für Onboard Mission Plans. Das sind, wenn man so will, Subroutinen in der Software, die vollautomatisch in einer bestimmten Sequenz ablaufen.
Das heißt, das Ding fährt sich im Wesentlichen erstmal aus, streckt sich, Antenne raus, Sonnensegel raus. Und was für einen Antrieb hat das ATV selbst?
Also das ATV hat insgesamt 28 Triebwerke. Davon sind vier der sogenannte Hauptantrieb. Das sind da so vier 500 Newton-Triebwerke, die am Boden, am Ende des ATVs, in der X-Achse montiert sind. Und dann gibt es, das kann ich nochmal zählen, 5, 4, ja. Ich hab gesagt, es gibt 28.
28 habe ich im Ohr, ja.
Sind aber 32. Es gibt vier Haupttriebwerke und 28 sogenannte Lage-Regelungstriebwerke. Die sind in Clustern zusammengefasst. Es gibt also am unteren Teil, gibt es vier Cluster. Davon hat jeder fünf Triebwerke. Und dann gibt es noch mal am vorderen Teil des ATVs vier weitere Cluster, wo jedes noch mal zwei Triebwerke hat. Das sind kleine Lage-Regelungstriebwerke. Davon hat jedes 200 Newton.
Und die Regelungstriebwerke, was heißt das? Die sind dann so beweglich und können so in jede Richtung?
Nein, die sind für die Lage-Regelung des ATVs verantwortlich. Die Haupttriebwerke kann man sich so vorstellen, die geben den Main-Schub nach vorne. Das sind auch die, die benutzt werden, wenn das ISS-Reboost gemacht wird. Und die anderen sind dafür verantwortlich, die Lage des ATVs im Raum zu regeln. Die Orientierung macht sogenannte SLU-Manöver, also Drehmanöver. Das ist das Yaw und Pitch, wie man es vom Flugzeug her kennt. Für diese Manöver ist das der Lage-Regelungstrieb.
Aber warum braucht man so viele? Zeigen die alle eine andere Richtung? Und man zündet dann immer genau das, was man gerade braucht?
Also erstmal gibt es bestimmte Redundanzen, auch hier wieder. Es gibt bestimmte Triebwerke, die sind reserviert für dieses sogenannte Collision-Avoidance-Manöver. Die werden für nichts anderes gebraucht. Und wir reden ja hier von einem Vehikel, was eine relativ hohe Trägheit hat und eine relativ große Präzision bei der Navigation haben soll. Es ist richtig, dass die Triebwerke alle in unterschiedliche Richtungen ausgerichtet sind.
Also die Trägheit, weil es einfach so voll beladen ist, weil es einfach so schwer ist.
Ich will mal ein Beispiel nennen für die Präzision des ATVs, die sehr beeindruckend ist, finde ich. Wenn man sich den Docking-Konus im Service-Modul der ISS anguckt, wo das Vehikel dann reinfährt, der hat so ungefähr einen Durchmesser von einem Meter dieser Konus. Und bei Soyuz und Progress ist das so, die kommen also an und treffen irgendwo in diesen Konus rein. Und dieser Konus führt sie dann mechanisch in die Mitte dieses Konus, wo sie dann am Ende verriegeln und angezogen werden und dann am Ende völlig angedockt sind. Der Konus wird als mechanische Führung benutzt. Und wenn Soyuz oder ein Progress ankommt, dann merken die Astronauten das auch, dass das hört man.
Weil es klackert.
Das hört man und es gibt teilweise sogar wohl auch Bewegungen, die man dann im Inneren merkt.
Also ein bisschen wie so ein Zug, wenn die Lokomotive angedockt.
Jetzt hatten wir ja eingangs gesagt, ein Progress ist ganz grob gesprochen ein Drittel ATV.
Von der Masse her.
Als Jules Verne ankam, haben die Astronauten gefragt, ist er schon da? Also Jules Verne hat die Mitte dieses Konus, und ich habe gesagt, der ist ein Meter Durchmesser, um zwei Zentimeter verfehlt. Was daran liegt, dass ATV eine wahnsinnsgenaue Guidance and Navigation and Control-System hat. Johannes Kepler war übrigens noch schlimmer, der hat das Ziel nur um halben Zentimeter verfehlt.
Also Johannes Kepler ist die zweite Mission, die jetzt gerade aktuell ist.
Ja, die zweite Mission, da hat also gar keiner mehr gemerkt, dass da was angekommen ist. Jedenfalls nicht vom Geräusch und von der Akustik.
Okay, und um diese Präzision zu erreichen, muss man sehr feinfühlig steuern können. Und dazu ist eben eine Vielzahl an genau arbeitenden Kleinsttriebwerken erforderlich, um die Bewegung genau zu steuern.
Das und wie gesagt, das Thema Redundanz ist eine wichtige Faktor. Und was noch ein Faktor ist, dass einige Triebwerke reserviert sind für Funktionen, für auch Contingency, also Notfallkonfiguration, und deshalb gar nicht involviert sind in der normalen Lage-Regelung.
Okay, kommen wir vielleicht nochmal zurück zu dem Flug als solchen. Also das Ding ist abgedockt, spült erstmal alles einmal durch, um sozusagen einsatzbereit zu sein. Und ab dem Moment, wo das ATV nicht mehr mit dieser letzten Raketenstufe verbunden ist, wo befindet sich das ATV relativ zur ISS? Wie weit ist das noch entfernt? Wird das dann schon in unmittelbare Nähe geschossen? Muss man noch ein paar Meter oder ist das ganz woanders?
Also du hast gerade gesagt abgedockt. Was du meintest, war separiert. Abgedockt, sagen wir immer, wenn wir von der ISS verstehen.
Wenn es mit einem Dock zu tun hat, ok, alles klar.
Also wir hatten ja gesagt, wir sind auf einem Zirkular in Orbit, 260 Kilometer. ISS flog, wenn wir jetzt das Beispiel Johannes Kepler nehmen, auf einer Höhe von 380 Kilometer. Also da fehlen noch 120 Kilometer.
Höhe.
Und jetzt ist es so...
Ist die Geschwindigkeit denn ähnlich zu dem Zeitpunkt?
ATV ist schneller. Und das passiert jetzt, dass das, naja, ist nicht... Es hat eine höhere Winkelgeschwindigkeit. Wir müssen unterscheiden zwischen Absolutgeschwindigkeit auf dem Orbit und Winkelgeschwindigkeit. Die Winkelgeschwindigkeit von ATV ist schneller. Und das machen wir uns eben auch zu nutzen. Das ist das sogenannte Phasing. Also zwischen dem ATV-Launch und dem Docking, da vergehen ja acht Tage. Man kann sich das so vorstellen, während diese acht Tage fliegt ATV auf einem kleineren Orbit, aber schneller von der Winkelgeschwindigkeit her als die ISS. Und dadurch kann man steuern, in dem Moment, wann gebe ich welches Manöver, um etwas höher zu fliegen, kann man den Annäherungs-Trajectory so berechnen, dass man mehr oder weniger hinter der ISS hochkommt. Das heißt, man fliegt nicht auf dem Orbit der ISS, um sich dann der ISS zu nähern, sondern man kommt von unten, wartet auf den richtigen Zeitpunkt raus und schiebt sich dann ein bisschen weiter nach hinten.
Höhere Winkelgeschwindigkeit heißt, dass wenn das ATV denselben Abstand zur Erde hätte, wie die ISS, wäre es schneller. Das heißt, dieser ganze Anhäherungsprozess ist eigentlich so ein Abwägen, zu welchem Zeitpunkt schiebt man sich wieder ein bisschen nach außen, fliegt weiter, um einfach den richtigen Zeitpunkt zu finden. Aber im Prinzip ist das jetzt nichts, wo man sagt, okay, jetzt sind wir draußen, jetzt gucken wir mal, wie wir da am besten hinkommen, sondern schon der Startzeitpunkt ist genau daraufhin ausgerichtet, dass man den idealen Weg findet.
Der Startzeitpunkt ist ausgerichtet, ATV kann immer nur an einem bestimmten Tag um eine bestimmte Uhrzeit fliegen. Und das liegt daran, dass die ISS fliegt auf einem Orbit mit einer Inklimation von 51,6 Grad. Und wir müssen dann starten, wenn praktisch die ISS gerade über diesen Orbit, über Kuru ist. Wenn dieser Orbit über Kuru ist, an dem Moment müssen wir starten.
Was heißt genau Inklimation?
Inklimation ist, also der Äquator ist Null. Und 51,6 Grad dazu ist die Inklimation des Orbits gemessen am Äquator. Und diese 51,6 Grad ergeben, das ist der Orbit der ISS. Ich glaube, der ergibt sich über die geographische Lage vom Baikonur, von wo die ersten Stationselemente geschossen wurden. Da bin ich ganz sicher. Jedenfalls der Starttermin legt sich daran fest, wann der 51,6 Grad Orbit der ISS Kuru schneidet. Wenn wir später oder früher fliegen würden, müssten wir mehr oder weniger laterale Manöver machen, um uns auf diesen Orbit zu bringen. Und das ist extrem treibstoffintensiv. Deshalb haben wir also kein Launch-Window, wie viele andere Satelliten, sondern wir haben ein Launch-Date.
Das heißt, man schießt so los, dass man im Idealfall, nur der Idealfall zählt, quasi von vornherein parallel zur ISS ist?
Nein, dass man am gleichen Orbit ist. In der gleichen Ebene.
Ja, okay, das meinte ich. Aber verstehe, okay, dass man genau in dem Moment, wo die ISS sozusagen auf der Höhe von Kuro ist, auch startet, dass man eben mit der ISS parallel fliegt.
Was jetzt noch eine Besonderheit ist von ATV, diese sogenannte Phasing Duration, also zwischen Start und Docking, diese acht Tage sind relativ lang. Wenn man sich jetzt Shuttle anguckt oder Soyuz anguckt oder auch Progress, die docken zwei, drei Tage später, Maximum. Bei Soyuz und Progress ist ja logisch, da ist Crew an Bord. Im Shuttle kann man vielleicht noch normal sitzen. Im Soyuz macht man das nicht so lange. Das liegt dann daran, dass der Launcher, praktisch das Launch Date, wird adaptiert an dem Termin, wann die sogenannte Phasing Duration das Minimum erreicht hat. ATV muss mit allen sogenannten Phasing Angles klarkommen können. Das heißt also, wenn die Ebene der ISS an dem Moment, wo es über KU fliegt, am ungünstigsten ist, sodass ATV ganz viele Orbits fliegen muss, um sich dann da langsam hochzuschaukeln, weil zum Beispiel ATV gerade vor der ISS gestartet wurde, das erklärt diese acht Tage. Aber für die Missionen, die eben bemannt sind, muss man das sehr, sehr kurz halten. Das heißt, der Launch-Termin, der Tag wird so ausgerechnet, dass die Phasing-Duration kurz ist. Das können wir für ATV nicht machen, weil wir auf einem kommerziellen Launcher fliegen. Und da kann man den Launch-Termin nicht anpassen. Also unser Arianz-Bus würde sich nicht sagen lassen, es geht nur der Tag, weil da brauchen wir nur zwei Tage zur Station. Da gibt es auch keinen zwingenden Grund für.
Das heißt, theoretisch könnte man es genauso machen, dass man auch in zwei Tagen oben ist. Aber aus Kostengründen nimmt man einfach die Möglichkeit, wir verbrauchen immer noch wenig Treibstoffe, aber es dauert unter Umständen lang.
Für bemannte Missionen betrachtet man sogar, ob man nicht mal den Orbit der ISS für einen Moment absenkt, um diese Phasing-Duration kurz zu halten. Das geht also auch noch.
Weil das billiger wäre, weil man schneller und einfacher hochkommt?
Oder weil es einfach so wichtig ist, an den Tag zu kommen.
Ah ja, verstehe. Aber das ist so bisher noch nicht gemacht worden.
Muss ich passen, das ist auf jeden Fall eine Option.
So, zurück zum ATV. Nach der Separation muss er sich jetzt also hoch hangeln. Er befindet sich auf derselben Ebene und schiebt sich aber immer weiter nach außen, um dann irgendwann möglichst nah und dann im Idealfall genau in demselben Orbit zu fliegen, wie die ISS.
Ja, also das nennen wir Phasing, dieses Hochschieben. Und dann kommen wir irgendwann in den Punkt, den wir nennen S-1½. Ich frage mich jetzt nicht, warum der so heißt.
Schade.
Der ist ungefähr 39 Kilometer hinter der ISS und auch leicht niedriger als die ISS. Und von diesem Punkt an beginnt dann das eigentliche Rendezvous-Manöver. Dann kommen jetzt auch, sag ich mal, die verschiedenen Sensoren des ATVs ins Spiel. Während der sogenannten Phasing-Duration benutzt ATV insbesondere den Star-Tracker und das sogenannte Absolute GPS. Absolute GPS ist das, was viele von uns im Auto haben. Ich bin grob hier und mit dem Star-Tracker weiß er, in welcher Position zum Sternenhimmel bin ich. Und das reicht also auch aus bis zu diesen 39 Kilometern. Und dann schaltet ATV um auf das sogenannte relative GPS. Das relative GPS, da passiert Folgendes. ATV kriegt ja seine Positionsdaten vom GPS-System selbst, aber auch die ISS bekommt seine Positionsdaten vom GPS-System. Und beim relativen GPS-System werden die beiden Daten von ATV und ISS verglichen. Und darüber wird praktisch die Lage der beiden Vehikel zueinander ermittelt.
Das heißt, es läuft über die Bodenstation?
Nein, das läuft direkt über den sogenannten Proximity Link. Das ist diese Antenne, die da hochklappt unter anderem.
Das heißt, ISS und ATV funktionieren schon miteinander?
ISS und ATV unterhalten sich direkt miteinander.
Und ISS sagt, ich bin hier, und ATV sagt, ich denke aber, ich bin hier, und dann ist das die Basis.
Und dieses relative GPS, was natürlich genauer ist, das ist das absolute GPS, das ist in Betrieb bis 250 Meter vor Docking. Und bei 250 Meter vor Docking wird es spannend. Das ATV unterschaltet ATV um auf das sogenannte Videometer. Das Videometer ist ein optischer Sensor, der mit Lasertechnologie arbeitet. Und vereinfacht gesprochen wirft er seine Laser auf das Service Module, auf die zylindrische Fläche, wo auch der Docking-Cone sitzt, wo er am Ende docken will. Und da sind, wenn man so will, kleine Spiegel montiert. Dieser Laserstrahl wird praktisch auf diese Spiegel geworfen, werden reflektiert und kommen wieder zurück und werden von dem gleichen Gerät wieder aufgenommen. Und damit misst er auf der einen Seite, wie weit bin ich noch weg, aber auch, wie schnell näher ich mich der ISS. Und zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt wird also diese Videometerfunktion sogar noch dahingehender gesagt, in welchem Winkel näher ich mich der ISS an.
Falls das Ding irgendwie so ein bisschen gekippt ist.
Dieses Videometer ist in sich erstmal nicht in sich nicht. Es gibt zwei davon. Also wenn eins ausfällt, würde das andere übernehmen. Und selbst wenn das ausfällt, dann haben wir schon den zweifachen Fehlerfall. In dem Fall wäre es ein Missionsabbruch. Was ich aber eigentlich sagen wollte, dieser Backup-Computer, den es auf dem ATV gibt, der benutzt zwei völlig unabhängige optische Sensoren. Das sogenannte Telegonometer funktioniert ähnlich, ist aber nicht identisch. Funktioniert auch mit Laser. Telegonometer. Davon gibt es auch zwei. Was ich einfach sagen will, ist, dieser Backup-Computer arbeitet mit unabhängigen Sensoren. Das heißt also, sollten diese Videometer irgendwelche unsinnigen Informationen liefern, hat er immer noch seine Unabhängigkeit gewahrt, weil er mit unabhängigen Sensoren arbeitet.
Das heißt, es gibt verschiedene Methoden, zum selben Ziel zu kommen. Man möchte erst einmal mit den Lasern arbeiten, aber sollten die in irgendeiner Form ausfallen?
Wenn nur noch die Telegonometer gehen, würde man nicht mehr docken, weil dann hat man schon zwei Fehlerfälle gehabt, beide Videometer ausgefallen, dann wäre die Mission vorbei.
Wie viele von diesen Wechseln zwischen vollautomatischen Phasen und Rücksprache mit der Bodenstation und neuer Entscheidungen, was man tun soll, haben wir denn jetzt durch zu dem Zeitpunkt? Seit der Separation?
Seit der Separation wären zu viele, weil jede Hochstufung sowas ist. Da werden praktisch immer neue Parameter berechnet. Und dann sagt Kontrollzentrum, ja, ist okay, oder gibt es sogar die Parameter. Ich würde mich jetzt beschränken wollen auf die letzten 250 Meter. Und da gibt es drei Kontrollpunkte, wo also ATV mehr, der stehen bleibt, sagt, hier sind meine Daten. Mit was ich jetzt weitermache, ist das okay. Kontrollzentrum sagt okay, und er geht weiter bis zum nächsten sogenannten Holdpoint, also wo er stehen bleibt.
Was machen denn die Astronauten in der ISS zu dem Zeitpunkt?
Ja, die kommen gleich ins Spiel. Der erste Holdpoint ist bei 250 Meter, der zweite ist bei 25 Meter und der letzte bei 11. So, und ich sag mal, bei dem bei 25 Metern, da sieht die Crew also den ATV schon sehr, sehr deutlich. Und die Crew hat außen am Board des Service Moduls eine Kamera installiert, die also dem ATV genau im Blick hat. Und diese Kamera hat also ein, wie soll man das sagen, eine Art Muster auf der Linse, das der Crew erlaubt, und das hört sich jetzt ein bisschen banal an, funktioniert aber blendend mit einem Plastik-Lenial, heißt doch Ruler das Ding, auf diesem Bildschirm bestimmte Abgleiche zu machen und damit mehr oder weniger manuell abzulesen, wie schnell kommt das Ding, wie weit ist er noch weg und verifiziert das mit den Daten, und jetzt kommt noch eine zusätzliche Komplikation, mit den Daten, die sie unter anderem vom sogenannten KURS-System zur Verfügung gestellt bekommen. Das KURS-System ist ein russisches radarbasiertes System, was auf der einen Seite am ATV montiert ist und auf der anderen Seite am Service-Modul. Das System in sehr ähnlicher Form existiert auch an Progress und Soyuz, war beim ersten ATV gedacht als Backup, um also die neuen ATV-Systeme zu verifizieren, zu validieren. Und mittlerweile ist dieses ältliche System leider Standard geworden, weil es eben für das sogenannte Independent-Q-Monitoring, also für das unabhängige Verifizieren der Q, nun ein fester Bestandteil geworden ist, weil dieses Kurssystem eben auch über einen Bildschirm, den die Crew lesen kann, sehen kann, wie schnell und nähert sich das Vehikel und wie weit es ist weg. Das System ist viel, viel ungenauer als die Daten, die ATV liefert, aber man will halt so große wie mögliche unabhängige Beurteilung während dieses Rondevues haben. Also die Crew sieht, wie der ATV kommt und hat also verschiedene Möglichkeiten einzuschätzen, wie schnell, wie weit ist er weg und in welcher Position kommt er an. Und ganz wichtig ist er in diesem sogenannten vorgeschriebenen Approach-Korridor. Es gibt einen bestimmten chronischen Korridor, in dem sich der ATV auf seinen Weg zur ISS hin bewegen muss. Wenn er diesen Korridor verlässt, würde er sowieso automatisch das sogenannte Escape einleiten, weil das Guidance and Navigation Control System ist so gebaut, dass er diesen Korridor nie verlässt. Sollte er diesen Korridor trotzdem verlassen, würde also automatisch, und das hat auch nichts mehr mit Kontrollzentren zu tun, würde ATV ganz automatisch von selber sagen, irgendwas stimmt bei mir nicht, ich flieg wieder zurück.
Ja, aber es ist sozusagen immer noch ein Backup von Backup vorgesehen.
Und das letzte Backup ist eben, dass auch die Crew noch diesen roten Knopf hat, weil sie über Kamera gucken kann, wo ist er denn, wie kommt er denn.
Also sollten sozusagen alle Computer verrückt spielen und die Maschinen schon übernommen haben, Skynet kommt, dann könnte die Crew immer noch sagen, das kommt uns spanisch vor, wir brechen das mal ab. Aber so ist es dann nicht gekommen. Sondern es ist beim ersten und beim zweiten Mal genauso gelaufen. Das heißt, erstmal 250 Meter Abstand. In dem Moment muss ja die Bodenstation entscheiden. Was überprüft man denn in dem Moment? Also das Kontrollzentrum, das vier Jahre am Anfang, ist in Toulouse. Von dort aus wird das alles gestartet. Genau, überwacht. Sind die Russen denn in dem Moment auch noch mit involviert?
Während des Dockings sind im Prinzip alle Kontrollzentren, die für die ISS zuständig involviert. Es ist also so, dass wir im Moment docken wir über dem sogenannten Russian Ground Segment, d.h. wir docken an die ISS, wenn es einen direkten Telemetrie-Telecommand-Link gibt von dem Kontrollzentrum Moskau zur ISS. Also wenn die ISS gerade Moskau im weitesten Sinne überfliegt, man hat dann also ungefähr 20 Minuten Zeit, um direkt Befehle zu senden und Telemetrie zu bekommen. Und im Moment ist das Design so, wir docken während dieser Zeit, weil die Russen, da werden ihr Modul andocken, sich die Freiheit nehmen zu sagen, wir wollen da mitentscheiden aufgrund der Daten, die wir vom ATV sehen. Das heißt, es ist da völlige Transparenz. Sie sehen genau, was ATV macht, was die ATV-Daten sind. Und auch die hätten also, sag ich mal, die Autorität zu sagen, ist nicht. Sie können zwar keinen Knopf drücken, aber sie können, sag ich mal, uns sagen, wir wollen, dass die ISS den Knopf drückt. Das heißt, sobald dein Knopf zu drücken ist, im Prinzip läuft alles automatisch. Ich könnte zum Beispiel ihrer Coup sagen, du drückst erst den Knopf.
Also wenn jetzt irgendein Fall eintritt, dass innerhalb dieses 20-Minuten-Fensters das Docking nicht vollständig abgeschlossen werden kann, würde man sozusagen noch mal eine Erdumdrehung abwarten?
Nicht eine Erdumdrehung, man würde dann diesen sogenannten Escape fliegen. Und dann würde man erst in 48 Stunden wieder kommen können.
Okay, also Abbrechen heißt immer, raus aus dem Orbit, irgendwas ist nicht in Ordnung, auf jeden Fall ATV in eine Position bringen. Da müsste er ja sozusagen um die ESL in der Ruf gehen.
Ob was nicht in Ordnung war, ist dann immer noch zu verifizieren, aber sagen wir mal, wenn Zweifel bestehen.
Genau, und der Zweifel ist über jeden Verdacht erhaben. Okay, 250 Meter, was überprüft man denn dann vor allem? Ist es jetzt wirklich nur so die Position oder gibt es da noch so andere Checks, die durchlaufen werden?
Im Prinzip muss man alles überprüfen, angefangen von dem Batterieladezustand, weil man braucht die Batterien später, wenn die sogenannte Probe eingezogen wird, Zustand der Stromversorgung, also der Solar Panel. Es sind eigentlich alle Funktionen, die überprüft werden, wenn irgendwas nicht geht, was Docking gefährden kann.
Das sind ja auch Sachen, die eigentlich permanent von allen Sensoren, von der Software die ganze Zeit überwacht werden. Wenn er jetzt bei 250 m stehen bleibt und man so einen expliziten jetzt muss das Kontrollzentrum entscheiden, auf welcher Basis entscheidet er?
Der ATV macht in regelmäßigen Abständen einen Downlink bestimmter sogenannte Housekeeping-Daten. Diese Housekeeping-Daten werden zwar auf der einen Seite vom ATV überprüft, und wenn er keinen Fehler meldet, ist gut, aber wieder das Thema Unabhängigkeit. Diese Housekeeping-Daten werden während dieser Kontrollschritten auch noch am Boden überprüft. Während dieser Holdpoints gibt es auch Uploads zum ATV hin. Das würde jetzt aber zu weit führen. Es gibt diese sogenannte MSU-Table. Diese MSU ist dieser Backup-Computer, von dem ich gesprochen habe. Der braucht bestimmte aktualisierte Daten, damit, wenn er dann ein Collision-Voidels-Manöver machen sollte, dafür auch die richtige Basis hat. Das würde jetzt sehr, sehr ins Detail gehen, wenn wir sagen, welche Daten werden da ausgetauscht an den verschiedenen Hotpoints.
Okay, gut. Aber das soll auch an der Stelle erst mal reichen. Das heißt, es ist hier vor allem eine Frage der Prozedur, und dass man eben noch Netz und doppelten Boden auch wirklich hat und aktivieren kann. Das Ding bleibt stehen, überträgt seine Sicht der Dinge, und es wird einfach unabhängig von dem ATV selbst auch nochmal festgestellt im Kontrollzentrum. So wollen wir das. Das ist sozusagen das Datenabbild, was wir sehen wollen, um auch wirklich sicher und verantwortungsvoll die Entscheidung fällen zu können, dass wir jetzt auf die nächste Annäherungsstufe gehen. Und dann sind das 25 Meter, und dann sind das nochmal 11. Warum wird da nochmal in zwei Schritten unterschieden? Ist ja eigentlich schon alles relativ nah dran. Da könnte man ja auch gleich hinfliegen. Oder ist das einfach auch nochmal ein weiteres Netz, dass man sagt, man macht halt einfach drei Schritte? Oder gibt es da noch einen technischen Grund?
Also warum jetzt 25 und nicht 26 und warum 11 und nicht 12? Die Antwort kann ich nicht geben. Es hängt mit Sicherheit damit zu tun, was die Crew sehen kann zu dem Zeitpunkt. Es gibt am ATV das sogenannte Visual-Video-Tage. Das ist, wenn man so will, ein beleuchtetes Fadenkreuz, was über einen Spiegel optisch sichtbar ist für die Crew. Dieses Fadenkreuz wird auch benutzt mit diesem Plastik-Lenial und der Kamera, die die Crew sieht, die Lage und erst mal die Lage des ATVs selber, seinen Winkel, aber auch die Position im Korridor festzustellen. Und die Crew braucht auch eine gewisse Zeit, um zu sagen, ja, das haben wir jetzt verifiziert, alles okay. Und dafür muss man anhalten.
Das heißt, ATV checkt, Kontrollzentrum checkt, die Astronauten auf der ISS checkt. Und wenn alle sagen prima, dann gibt es den nächsten Schritt. Und dann am Schluss nochmal bei elf Metern Abstand. Und dann geht es ans eigentliche Docking. So, das haben wir ja schon im Prinzip angerissen. Das ATV hat dann vorne so eine Nase, so einen Stab.
Man kann sich das vorstellen wie ein länglicher Zylinder, der vorne so eine halbkugelförmige Kappe hat. Diese halbförmige kugelige Kappe hat allerdings sehr viele Bauteile. Das sind sogenannte Haken drin, Hucks. Es gibt also einmal eine Verriegelung, wo die Kappe von dem ATV dieser Haken ausfährt, um sich in der ISS zu verriegeln. Aber auch die ISS verriegelt von ihrer Seite aus.
Also zwei Hände, die ineinander greifen?
Nein, weil die beiden Hände greifen nicht ineinander. Das wird an verschiedenen Stellen gegriffen. Jedes Teil für sich, das ist ein Thema Redundanz, würde die mechanische Verriegelung gewährleisten können. Jetzt ist diese Probe ungefähr einen Meter lang, die die Distanz zwischen dem Docking-Interface, ISS und ATV ausmacht. Jetzt wird diese Probe ATV-seitig elektrisch eingefahren und zieht damit das Interface vom ATV an das Interface der ISS. Jetzt werden diese beiden Interfaces aligned zusammengeführt. Dann kommt das eigentliche mechanische Verriegeln von diesem Interface. Es gibt auch wieder Haken ATV-seitig, die dieses Interface verriegeln, als auch ISS-seitig. Dann ist tatsächlich die mechanische Integrität zwischen ATV und ISS gegeben. Dann gibt es noch das elektrische Docking, wenn man so will, weil es werden ja auch elektrische Interfaces verbunden, in dem Moment, wo diese beiden Interfaces zusammengezogen werden. Electrical Merging nennt man das. Und dann ist der eigentliche Docking-Vorgang erstmal abgeschlossen. Dann gibt es ja sehr viel später. Normalerweise wird erst am Tag danach das sogenannte Ingress gemacht. Das Ingress ist, wenn die Crew das sogenannte Hatch, also die Klappe, aufmacht, mit der man dann in den ATV reingehen kann.
Das findet den ersten Tag später statt?
Das findet in der Regel den ersten Tag später statt, weil es noch eine ganze Reihe von Überprüfungen gibt, die dann eben erstmal nach dem mechanischen Docking stattfinden. Es gibt dazu noch so ein kleines Intercompartment, wo ein Druckausgleich gemacht werden muss. Und wenn die Crew dann eben das Hatch geöffnet hat, dann tut sie das mit einer Atemmaske auf, weil man weiß ja erstmal nicht, ist vielleicht irgendwas kaputt gegangen oder wie ist die Qualität der Atmosphäre? Wenn wir starten, wissen wir natürlich, wie die Qualität der Atmosphäre ist. Es werden sehr aufwendige Prüfungen gemacht über die Bestandteile der Atmosphäre im ATV. Da gibt es ja sehr, sehr hohe Anforderungen.
Aber dann auch noch mal als Sicherheitsmaßnahme? Das heißt, es wird dann auch verschleust? Also in dem Moment, wo man das Hatch öffnet zum ATV, ist der Rest der ISS dann noch mal?
Nein, das ist nicht der Fall. Man macht dann also noch mal an, nachdem das Hatch offen ist und dieses Ingress stattgefunden hat, macht man auch noch mal eine Prüfung der Qualität der Atmosphäre. Und sollte man jetzt also feststellen, da gibt es was für sich, so viel Staub oder so, gibt es noch mal ein extra, das Ding heißt Scrubber, das stellt man rein, wird elektrisch betrieben, das noch mal die Luft reinigt.
Wie so diese Bäumchen im Auto.
Gut, also man kann dann sozusagen zur Not auch noch so was ausgleichen, aber dass jetzt irgendwie giftige Gase sich entwickeln, das ist eigentlich ausgeschlossen aufgrund der verwendeten Bauteile und auch jedes einzelne Item, was also mit ATV transportiert wird, wird einem sehr aufwändigen Review unterzogen.
Jetzt sind da ja zahlreiche Dinge drin, Treibstoffe und Gase. Wie kriegt man die denn jetzt wieder raus? Muss man dann jetzt so Tanks raustragen oder legt man da Schläuche rein oder ist mit dieser Verbindung auch automatisch, werden auch automatisch so Treibstoffkanäle mit verbunden?
Das ist verschieden. Also was das Refueling-System betrifft, also die Treibstoffe, die in die ISS gepumpt werden, da ist es so, dass während des Dockings werden zwar Verbindungen hergestellt, aber da fließt erstmal noch nichts. In diesem System sitzen ATV-seitig sogenannte Pyroventile, die, wenn man den Transfer machen will, dann geschossen werden und dann wird praktisch das System bedrückt und die Treibstoffe werden rüber gefördert vom ATV in die ISS.
Die werden freigespringt?
Na ja, Pyroventile können sehr, sehr, man schaltet Leitungen frei. Dann haben wir Gas und Wasser und dafür gibt es im Inneren des ATV bestimmte, speziell vorgesehene Control Panel. Da kann man sich vorstellen, Knöpfe dran und Ventile dran, die man drehen kann. Und damit kann man eben dann die Gase oder Flüssigkeiten freilassen. Zum Beispiel, wenn Sauerstoff in die ISS gepumpt wird, dann wird das stufenweise gemacht. Es sind also 100 Kilogramm Gas, die die ATV transportieren kann. Die werden nicht auf einmal in die ISS gespült, sondern das wird stufenweise gemacht, auch nach Bedarf. Und dafür gibt es eben Ventile zum Öffnen, sehen ähnlich aus wie ein Wasserhahn. Und beim Wasser gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Beim Wasser gibt es also die Möglichkeit, das direkt in Wassertanks der ISS zu transformieren. Man kann es aber auch manuell machen, in sogenannte Rottnickstanks. Das sind tragbare Tanks, wo tatsächlich ein Schlauch von den ATV-Tanks in diese tragbaren Tanks verlegt wird und dann von den Astronauten in der ISS zu den jeweiligen Wassertanks transportiert wird.
Warum muss man das machen? Weil das nicht so jetzt komplett durch verschlaucht ist alles?
Erstens das und zweitens gibt es noch eine Besonderheit, das gibt an Bord der ISS russisches Wasser und amerikanisches Wasser. Also Wasser ist nicht gleich Wasser. Diese Wasser haben verschiedene Bestandteile. Bei den Amerikanern ist glaube ich Silber drin, bei den Russen...
Ach, das hat eine unterschiedliche Zusammensetzung.
Warum?
Offensichtlich haben die amerikanischen und russischen Mediziner unterschiedliches Verständnis von, was ist das beste Wasser für ihre Astronauten. Wir reden ja von Trinkwasser.
Ach, und die amerikanischen Astronauten, die trinken nur das amerikanische Wasser?
So ist es. Ob das nun an Bord der ISS am Ende so gemacht wird, man weiß es nicht.
Aber man hat sozusagen zwei Geschmacksorten zur Auswahl.
Ich habe auch noch nicht probiert, ob die unterschiedlich schmecken, aber es sind auf jeden Fall zwei verschiedene Wasser, die auch entsprechend gekennzeichnet sind.
So ein bisschen Raumstation-Esoterik, was man so am liebsten trinkt, was einem so am meisten Energien bringt. Okay, und im ATV kommt aber nur russisches Wasser, oder?
ATV ist für beide Wasser qualifiziert und wir haben tatsächlich zwei Qualifikationstests gemacht, um beide Wasser zu qualifizieren.
Und es wird wirklich amerikanisches und russisches Wasserseparat hochgeflogen. So, und der Rest ist das ganze Dry Cargo, das Trockenmaterial, das ist dann so in so Containern verpackt.
Das sind sogenannten Crew Transportation Bags. Das sind so weiße, meist rechteckige Boxen, die dann in der Regel noch bestimmte Schaumladungen haben, je nachdem, was jetzt da drin ist. Die haben natürlich auch verschiedene Größen. Gewicht spielt ja an Bord dann keine Rolle mehr. Und die werden eben manuell von der Crew entladen.
Und dann trägt man sie einfach dahin. Wie lange dauert das, bis alles so ausgeladen ist? Das scheint ja schon ein etwas länglicher Prozess zu sein.
Das kann man so nicht sagen. Das hängt natürlich immer davon ab, was wird gerade wann an der ISS benötigt. Wenn etwas nicht zwanghaft benötigt wird, lässt man es erstmal da. Weil Lagerraum in der ISS ist ja eine knappe Ressource. Und man ist eigentlich auch froh, solange ATV da ist, den auch, wenn man so will, als zusätzliches Volumen zu haben. Und es gibt deshalb keinen Zwang, sofort alles auszuräumen, kurz nachdem wir angedockt haben.
Wie lange bleibt denn das ATV? Was bestimmt die Dauer, die Aufenthaltsdauer des ATV? Also eigentlich lässt man das so lange da, bis der Platz wieder für das nächste Vehikel gebraucht wird. Weil ist ja schön, dass es da ist. Und solange kann man da rein und raus tragen. Oder gibt es da irgendwie so einen Zeitraum, den man nicht überschreiten darf?
Also ATV ist erstmal qualifiziert für eine angedockte Phase von maximum sechs Monaten. Danach sind alle Bauteile ausgelegt. Wenn man das deutlich verlängern würde, dann müsste nachqualifiziert werden. Kürzer ist natürlich kein Problem. Und wovon ist das jetzt abhängig, ob das drei oder sechs Monate sind? Das hängt wiederum davon ab, wie die Ressourcen, die ATV hochbringt, an Bord genutzt werden. Wenn z.B. nur wenig so genannter Propulse Support, also ATV, nur wenig benutzt wird, um die ISS-Lagerregelung zu unterstützen und die anderen logistischen Sachen auch schon früh entladen werden, gibt es keinen Grund mehr, ihn länger da zu behalten. Also Jules Verne war, glaube ich, sechs Monate und sogar zwei Wochen, da haben wir diese Qualifikation leicht ausdehnen müssen, angedockt. Und wenn es dabei bleibt, dass ATV 2 am 20. Juni abdockt, dann war es also ungefähr nur fünf Monate da. Hat aber trotzdem alle seine Missionsziele dann erreicht.
Das heißt, man ist eigentlich ganz froh, solange es da ist, dass es da ist, weil es einfach zusätzlich einen Platz bietet. Und am Schluss ist man aber dann, irgendwann muss man ja auch anfangen, alles reinzutragen, was nicht mehr gebraucht wird. Die Abwasser müssen reingepumpt werden.
Der Prozess ist sogar ein bisschen komplizierter. Hier kommt wieder das Kontrollzentrum ins Spiel. Für das Funktionieren der Lageregelung von ATV selber ist es natürlich wichtig, dass bestimmte Grenzen, was die Massenverteilung dieser Cargo im ATV betrifft, eingehalten werden. Deshalb wird während der gesamten Phase von Launch bis Undocking vom Kontrollzentrum überprüft, wo sind welche Massen im ATV, weil wir müssen immer in einem bestimmten Bereich sein, um auch im Fall einer Notfall jederzeit ein Undocking machen zu können. Das heißt, es gibt eine permanente Kontrolle des sogenannten MCI, Mars Center of Gravity and Inertia, um sicherzugehen, dass wir zu jeder Zeit abfliegen können, wenn es denn verlangt werden soll.
Verstehe, also man kann nicht einfach da was reinfeuern, wie sein Zelt, sondern man muss immer sagen, ich lege jetzt eine Tasche hier rein und zwar dahin.
Und man muss auch noch sagen, welche Tasche.
Klar, okay, verstehe, weil jederzeit kann die Reißleine gezogen werden und wir müssen jetzt hier abdocken, warum auch immer und dann so.
Also wir müssen theoretisch in der Lage sein, binnen 48 Stunden jederzeit ein Undocking machen zu können. Aber dafür muss natürlich dieses Mars Center of Gravity and Inertia Control permanent gemacht werden. Damit können wir eigentlich 48 Stunden vorher anfangen.
Was könnte denn jetzt so ein Grund sein, dass man da jetzt nochmal abdocken muss? Weil eigentlich, ich meine, wenn jetzt ein Einschlag droht, dann würde man das ATV ja eh nutzen, um die ESS zu bewegen. Wann müsste man denn abdocken?
Ein Beispiel könnte zum Beispiel sein, dass ein ATV-System ausgefallen ist und damit eine bestimmte Redundanz nicht mehr gegeben ist. Und man sagt, okay, wenn das jetzt nur noch einfache Funktionalität da ist und jetzt würde das zweite System auch noch ausfallen, dann können wir kein Undocking mehr machen. Deshalb müssen wir ein Undocking machen, nachdem das erste System ausgeführt wird. So schlimm wie möglich weg. Ein Beispiel, genau.
Okay, bevor es noch schlimmer wird. So, und wenn dann alles ausgeladen ist, was man braucht, und alles eingeladen ist, was man nicht mehr braucht, dann dockt das System wieder ab. Das ist wahrscheinlich ein relativ unkomplizierter Vorgang im Vergleich zum Andocken. Oder ist das auch wieder alles nicht so einfach?
Naja, wir haben zumindest Haken auf vier Seiten, die wieder entriegelt werden müssen. Es müssen auch vorher eine ganze Menge Daten in den Computer des ATVs wieder eingelesen werden. Eben aufgrund des Datums, wann er denn nun andockt, braucht er bestimmte Daten, damit er dann auch weiß, okay, wie sieht meine Trajektorie aus, um an dem vorgesehenen Punkt dann das Vienti durchzuführen. Das Antriebssystem muss natürlich wieder vorbereitet werden, weil je nachdem, wann die letzten Operationen des Antriebssystems waren, um die ISS zu unterstützen, kann es sein, dass es nochmal bestimmte Vorbereitungsmaßnahmen geben muss, um das Antriebssystem wieder scharf zu schalten für die ATV-Mission.
Dann hat man im Idealfall auch noch genug Sprit übrig, um das ganze Manöver durchzuführen und um sich dann an der richtigen Stelle in den Pazifik zu stürzen.
Das ist nicht der Ideal, sondern der Nominalfall. Es ist sogar so, dass man so viel Propellant an Bord hat. Das sollte auf dem Weg des Re-Entries ein System ausfallen. Man könnte sich zum Beispiel vorstellen, dass eine sogenannte Propulsion Drive Electronics, das ist eine von den Elektronikboxen, die das Propallensystem steuert, komplett ausfällt. Das würde dann bedeuten, dass unter Umständen ein Set von Triebwerken, jede von diesen PDEs, steuert fünf, sieben Stück. Wenn diese sieben nicht mehr zur Verfügung stehen, dann stehen nur noch x andere zur Verfügung. Und damit ist der Wirkungsgrad dieser verbleibenden Triebwerke deutlich geringer. Und deshalb würde man mehr Treibstoff brauchen, um immer noch die gleiche Trajektorie zu fliegen. Und dieses Mehrtreibstoff ist natürlich als Margin in der Treibstoffmenge vorgesehen, die im ATV noch drin sein muss, wenn man abduckt. Also auch für das Re-Entry herrscht diese volle Redundanz. Weil ich sage mal, dass das Ding am richtigen Fleck runterkommt.
Das ist ja nicht unwichtig.
Das ist genauso wichtig, wie das es richtig anbaut.
Wie viel kommt denn überhaupt runter? Verglüht das Ding nicht weitgehend?
Es verglüht weitgehend. Es gibt natürlich Teile, die sind so groß und so massiv, die kommen runter. Wir haben damals bei Jules Verne den Wiedereintritt beobachtet. Wir hatten zwei Flugzeuge in der Luft, die das Ganze natürlich von entsprechender Entfernung gefilmt haben. Und wir haben das Ganze sogar von der ISS aus gefilmt, weil das Re-Entry war so gelegt, dass es erstens im Dunkeln war. Und dass es so passierte, dass die ISS gerade über dem Punkt war, wo ATV dann in die Atmosphäre eingetreten ist. Diese Analyse hat erst mal gezeigt, dass man das Re-Entry analytisch sehr gut berechnet hatte. Also erst mal sind wir sehr zielgenau runtergekommen. Und auch was diesen sogenannten Footprint betrifft, also auf welcher Fläche kommen die Einzelteile runter, auch da haben die Auswertungen gezeigt, dass die Vorhersagen sehr präzise sogar bis besser waren.
Wo ist es denn dann runtergekommen?
Im Südpazifik.
Im Südpazifik, da wo viel Platz ist.
Genau, und wo wenig Flug-
und Schifffarkehr ist. Das heißt, die erste Mission kann eigentlich nur als voller Erfolg gewertet werden. Man hat all diese ganzen Tests bestanden, man hat auch die ganzen Manöver gemacht, die man nicht jedes Mal immer wieder neu macht, sondern die nur das erste Mal alle ausgetestet wurden.
Die Mission war ein voller Erfolg. Es sind alle Ziele der Mission erreicht worden. Wir haben ja gesagt, das System hat bestimmte Redundanzen. Und wir haben also auch sehen können, dass manche Redundanz gebraucht wurde, weil Fehler passiert sind. Dafür haben wir eine Flugauswertung gemacht. Und wir haben aufgrund der Flugauswertung die Fehler erkannt und beim zweiten eliminiert. Da gab es einen Fehler im Antriebssystem. Der Fehler, der am meisten sichtbar war für diejenigen, die das Ganze im Internet verfolgt haben, war, dass sich die MLI vom ersten ATV an einigen Stellen aufgeblasen und sogar abgelöst hatte. Das ist die Multi-Layer-Insolation, das sind diese weißen, thermischen Isolationen, die auf der Außenhaut des ATVs angebracht sind.
Das war beim ersten, da hat sich das aufgebläht.
Genau, das war beim ersten. Da gab es auch ein kleines Problem in der Auslegung. Das haben wir dann in ein Redesign vorgenommen, haben das Ganze neu qualifiziert. Und wie man beim zweiten ATV gesehen hat, ist das noch mal passiert. Es gab schon einige Änderungen, auch software-seitig, die wir zwischen dem ersten und dem zweiten eingeführt haben. Es war nichts, was jetzt kritisch war für die erste Mission. Aber jeden Fehler, den man erkennt, der potenziell den Erfolg der Mission gefährden kann, dem verbessert man natürlich. Deshalb war es auch wichtig, dass wir uns von Anfang an die Zeit genommen hatten, zwischen dem ersten und dem zweiten zwei Jahre Zeit vergehen zu lassen. Während die nächsten wollen wir jetzt in einer Kadenz von einem jedes Jahr erschießen.
Das heißt, 2012 geht dann schon der dritte ATV nach oben?
Im Moment, kann ich sogar ein Datum sagen, 29.02.
Das ist sozusagen das Ziel für den Launch?
Genau.
Bisher ist man auch zuversichtlich, den so halten zu können, wenn nicht wieder was dazwischen kommt.
Jeder Schedule ist kritisch, aber wir kriegen das hin.
Was ist denn so dann die Zukunft von dem ATV? Baut man das Ding immer so weiter? Oder soll sich das noch weiter entwickeln in eine andere Richtung, dass es vielleicht irgendwann noch mal zurückkehrt und nicht komplett verglüht? Oder soll das jetzt erst mal so bleiben?
Also erstmal wollen wir davon in Summe fünf Stück bauen. Diese fünf Stück, oder warum fünf? Diese fünf sind notwendig, um die ESA-Schulden bei der NASA für den Betrieb von Columbus mindestens bis zum Jahre 2017 zu decken.
Also der Beitrag der ESA zum Gesamtaufwand der ESA.
Jetzt hat ja die ESA bzw. die Mitgliedsländer, die sich in diesem Programm beteiligen, gerade im März entschieden, dass sie die ESA auf jeden Fall bis 2020 betreiben wollen. Vielleicht noch weiter, aber bis 2020 hat man sich erst mal geeinigt. Sodass es jetzt also eine Lücke gibt von drei Jahren, was also diese fünf ATVs abdecken, bis 2017 hatte ich gerade gesagt, bis 2020. Und für diese drei Jahre haben wir eben ein bestimmtes Budget zur Seite gestellt. Und wir haben jetzt die Aufgabe, mit der NASA zu definieren, was könnte ein Bata-Element sein, um unsere Verspflichtungen für diese drei Jahre zu kompensieren. Das wird mit Sicherheit kein weiterer ATV sein. Und es wird auch mit Sicherheit nicht das, was im Jahre 2008 auf der Ministerratskonferenz in einer Phase A entschieden wurde, der sogenannte ARV, Automated Re-Entry Vehicle. Auch das wird es nicht sein. Aus verschiedenen Gründen. Ein Grund ist zum Beispiel, dass das Budget, was wir dort zurückgestellt haben und was wir auch nur brauchen, um diese drei Jahre zu begleichen, deutlich niedriger ist, als das Budget, was man bräuchte, wenn man einen ARV entwickeln würde.
Also ARV im Sinne von im Prinzip dieselbe Funktionalität wie das ATV, aber mit Rückkehrkapsel.
Dieser ARV war im Prinzip eine Ableitung des ATVs. Man hat diesen Cargo Carrier, der da vorne drauf ist, ersetzt durch eine Kapsel. Hier im Prinzip immer noch, gut, soweit ist man da nicht gegangen, wo docken wir, sind es die gleichen optischen Sensoren etc. Das Ganze ist in einer Phase A untersucht worden. Wir werden jetzt im Sommer nach dem sogenannten System Requirement Review aufhören. Das Ganze, sage ich mal, in einen dormant mode legen. Und uns erstmal mit der NASA darüber unterhalten, was braucht die ISS? Und was kann der ESA-Beitrag sein, um mit dem Budget, was wir uns da zur Seite gelegt haben und was noch notwendig ist, um diese drei Jahre zu bezahlen, was können wir da bringen? Und natürlich werden wir auch in die Richtung gucken, kann das, was wir da bringen, auch eine Anwendung haben für zukünftige Explorations-Programme, wie auch immer die aussehen. Im Moment sind alle internationalen Partner dabei, sich da die Karten zu legen, also das werden wir im Auge behalten.
Das heißt, ATV bleibt erst mal das ATV, so wie es ist, aber es ist durchaus vorstellbar, dass es noch weitere ATVs gibt, die in den Folgejahren über die bisherige Planung hinaus noch fliegen.
Also weitere ATVs über fünf, die Antwort ist zu verneinen, weil auch die Bauteile, die im ATV sind, ja aus einer Zeit stammen, wir haben das Programm 2000, naja, um 2000 haben wir angefangen, die Teile zu bestellen, wir haben die Teile für den ersten und die Folgemodelle teilweise zusammengestellt, und das sind teilweise Bauteile, die eben heute nicht mehr beschaffbar sind. Also man kann jetzt nicht sagen, ich fange in fünf Jahren nochmal an, einen Satz ATVs zu bauen, man könnte heute auch keine Saturn V mehr bauen. Insofern, der ATV, wie er heute ist, den könnte man nicht wieder bauen und eigentlich hätte man ja auch das Interesse, etwas zu bauen, was mehr kann oder was einem neuen Projekt zugute kommt. Was mit Sicherheit sein wird, ist, dass wir in Europa mit ATV uns eine Technologiebasis gebaut haben, die uns keiner nehmen kann. Es gibt kein anderes Vehikel, das automatisch dockt. Für mich ist die Core-Kompetenz, die wir mit ATV entwickelt haben, dieses wahnsinnig gut funktionierende Guidance and Navigation and Control System mit der Software und den Computern und den redundanten Systemen, die dahinter stehen. Das ist etwas, was man auch noch für zukünftige Exploration-Missionen brauchen kann, wo vielleicht Docking von unbemannten Systemen eine große Rolle spielen wird. Das Docking von unbemannten Systemen, das hat man seitens der NASA schon mal probiert vor längerer Zeit in einem Programm namens Darts. Da hat man festgestellt, wie schwierig das ist.
Das hat nämlich nicht geklappt.
Also mit Exploration-Missionen meinen wir jetzt etwas anderes als die ISS-Missionen zu anderen Kometen, Planeten, was auch immer?
Na ja, wenn wir von bemannt reden, dann sicher nicht Kometen. Ich denke, wenn man redet, dann redet man von Mond und Mars erstmal. Oder einfach auch nur andere Low-Earth-Orbit-Plattformen, ob jetzt nun bemannt oder nicht. Aber da hat ATV eine Menge Technologie einzubringen.
Also die Technologie bleibt. Aber das Projekt ist auf jeden Fall irgendwann auch mal zu Ende. Ja, haben wir noch etwas ganz Wichtiges unerwähnt gelassen. Ich glaube, wir haben fast alle Bereiche an der Podcastsitzung. Das stimmt. Kann auch immer nur ein Einblick gewesen sein, aber den haben wir jetzt bekommen. Vielen Dank, Nico Dettmann. Das ATV, das kleine Wunderfahrzeug, das sich automatisch an die ISS rankoppelt und auch wieder davonfliegt. War ein schöner Einblick hier bei Raumzeit. Und ja, damit sage ich für die heutige Ausgabe erstmal Tschüss und bis bald. Eine neue Folge wird kommen, wie es hier die Regel ist, alle zwei Wochen. Danke nochmal an Nico Dettmann. Danke fürs Zuhören und bis bald bei Raumzeit.